hi this is pressure Walker in this video
I'm going to describe the stable
marriage problem matching markets are
extremely important in economic theory
they're an example of how you get two
groups of people with different
interests to match up together for
example in the doctor residency match
you have residents who want to go to
certain hospitals and hospitals that
want certain residents and you need to
match those preferences up together
another example is the kidney exchange
where you have donors and patients who
may not be compatible as loved ones but
who can be paired up with another donor
patient pair in which they can be
compatible the Nobel Committee
recognised work in matching markets and
awarded the prize to Al Roth and Lloyd
chapli in 2012 for their work in
matching markets so how can matching
markets be difficult well here's an
example you can have what's known as an
unstable matching this happens when two
people who are not matched together
would prefer to be together over their
current assignment over their current
match so this would cause a problem
because those two people would just
break off from their current match and
be together
and that can lead to all sorts of
consequences so we're going to
illustrate this with some cards imagine
we have the four kings the king of heart
King of Spades King of Diamonds and king
of clubs and we have four queens the
hearts spades diamonds and clubs so how
would you batch up these pairs the kings
and the queens normally when playing
cards we match them up by suit cards
that are matched by suits and poker and
many games are usually stronger so
that's one natural mapping but we can
think about these cards representing
interests of four men and four women so
imagine the King of Hearts actually
wants to be with the queen of diamonds
and the queen of diamonds actually wants
to be with the king of hearts
these two what that would be an unstable
match and those two could break off and
get together and that would leave the
Queen of Hearts to be unmatched now
maybe the king of clubs says of the
Queen of Hearts is available and she
prefers to be in that rather than being
alone so those two get together and that
leaves the queen of clubs being
unmatched so you can see what the
dynamics are in a matching market when
you have an unstable match it's not a
good thing you could even tap to another
thing where the King of Spades and the
queen of clubs are now managed just to
end this let's just say the King of
Diamonds and the Queen of Spades want to
be together
this would be a match that would be
stable the Gail Shapley algorithm
developed in 1962 is a way that shows
you can always find a stable matching so
let's return to the example of men and
women in marriage which was one of the
examples given in the paper how does a
Gil Shapley algorithm work the first
step is that the men will prefer will
propose to their first choices they
think about all the women who are
available and they each propose to their
first choices the women if any of them
receive multiple proposals will then
pick their favorite from those choices
the men who are rejected will then
return to the drawing board and propose
to their second choice the women again
if any of them have multiple proposals
will pick the favor and will keep
repeating that where the rejected men
keep proposing to another choice and the
women keep picking their favorite until
each person is matched and when each
person is matched this will always be a
stable match
so let's do an example
where the men propose will return to the
cart example we have the Kings that
we're going to match with the Queens and
we're going to have to put preferences
on what each of the Kings and Queens
want so imagine the King of Hearts most
prefers to be with the queen of clubs
then the queen of diamonds the third
choice would be the Queen of Hearts and
the least preferred option would be the
Queen of Spades we're going to put this
type of ranked preference for each king
over what each king wants and we will
similarly do the same thing over each
Queen and what each Queen wants so the
Queen of Hearts most would want to be
with the King of Hearts
then diamonds clubs and spades and we'll
do the same thing for each individual
now we can apply the Gail Shipp Lee
algorithm so the men first proposed to
their most favorite choice the King of
Hearts would propose to the queen of
clubs the King of Spades would propose
as well to the queen of clubs
then we go to the King of Diamonds who
proposes to the Queen of Spades and
finally the king of clubs would propose
to his most favourite choice which is
the queen of diamonds in the second step
of the algorithm we look at the Queen's
and see - any of the Queen's have more
than one proposal before we do that
we'll just put in some markers to remind
ourselves of the preferences of the
Kings this will come in handy for the
following step after the Queen's look at
the proposals so here we have the queen
of clubs who's received two proposals so
she says all right I prefer the King of
Spades over the King of Hearts so she
rejects the King of Hearts who returns
back to the drawing board
so he's been rejected by the queen of
clubs so he now goes to a second choice
which is the queen of diamonds this will
mean the queen of diamonds now has two
proposals so she evaluates which one is
her favorite so the King of Hearts is is
favored over the king of clubs so she
rejects the king of clubs he goes back
to the drawing board
and we look at his preference choice so
now the King of clubs proposes to his
second choice which is the Queen of
Hearts and now each person is matched
and the algorithm stops so this by the
Galle Shapley algorithm is a stable
matching we have the king of spades and
the king of diamond end up with their
most favourite choice and the King of
Hearts and king of clubs end up with
their second favorite choice so that's
what happens when the men proposed but
let's see what happens when the women
propose
we'll return the Kings back to the their
preferences and now we'll imagine the
women are the ones who are doing the
proposal
so we look at the Queen of Hearts and
she prefers the King of Hearts so she
proposes to the King of Hearts the Queen
of Spades proposes to the king of clubs
the queen of diamonds proposes to the
King of Hearts and the queen of clubs
proposes to the king of spades now it's
the men's turn we look at if any of the
men have multiple proposals and we'll
just leave some cards to remember the
preferences of the Queen's so if we look
at the Kings the King of Hearts has
multiple proposals so now he evaluates
which option he prefers so he prefers
the queen of diamonds over the Queen of
Hearts so the Queen of Hearts is
rejected and now we look at the Queen of
Hearts preferences and see what her
second choices so she goes to the King
of Diamonds so now when the women
propose it's different this is not the
same matching we had before and all of
the women get their first choice except
one woman who gets her second choice
so the Galle Shapley algorithm will
always result in a stable matching but
there can be more than one stable
matching and it can depend on who is
doing the proposal and in general you
want to be the side that proposes
because then your side will have more
favorite outcomes I hope you like this
video please subscribe to my channel you
can get my books listed on my website
catch me on my blog minor decisions on
twitter at pressure locker and you can
support me on patreon for exclusive
rewards